welcome back to Drews news in Vegas as
we gear up for the Super Bowl this
weekend right here on CBS our family
station now Ross and I are here at the
desk with WF an's radio CBS Sports
Network host Boomer and Gia yes Boomer
and
Gio all right Rosy your story well okay
first of Drew since we are in Vegas the
land of Buffets and I know how
passionate you and I are about buffets
we you are I don't like it I don't like
it the buffets are here to stay if
you're a buffet lover you know what I'm
talking about if you're not maybe I can
change your mind I actually swung by the
buffet and I put together some tips and
tricks for everyone at home and to prove
to all of you cynic once and and all
buffets are Majestic Majestic yes take a
look all right you know Drew and I talk
a lot about my love of Buffets on the
news so I couldn't come to Vegas and not
go to the buffet at the bagio come with
[Music]
me I like to walk around and do a quick
just a spotting of what my options are
like where's they have Oysters should we
start building a plate what are we doing
I'm not dilly-dallying here come on
plate me oh thank you
okay so at a buffet I like to coarse it
out you know what I mean just like you
would at a restaurant ABS salad let's
start there look at her muffin see what
you're doing here a beautiful place I
have to say because you're keeping it
healthy over here and then muffin over
here and let's be honest you're not
really eating the salad I know you I
know what you're
doing what I love about buffets is it's
really a chance to take a trip around
the world right now see we just went
from Sushi to Pizza we just took a trip
from Asia to Italy in two
steps where else can you do
that you know I just love an option you
know you go into restaurants do you have
a what's the special of the day here I'm
in
charge so you're going to be very
tempted to start piling on right away
don't do it don't do it cuz right now
you know maybe the uh Sushi looks great
but two steps down there's going to be
French toast and it's not going to mix
so you just have to be very
strategic watch this trick is it a
balsamic day or Ranch day balsamic on
that side ranch on this side arrest
me okay now the most important step you
eat and then listen to this part
carefully once you're
done you go back and do it again Drew
have I convinced you are you a buffet
[Music]
now so so what do you think I actually
brought you food this is from the buffet
this is what I got I brought it here for
you Boomer there's some desserts and
salad that's half Ranch half uh
balsamic yeah I got you Oysters
Rockefeller you see the variety here
oysters we got cheese cubes We Got Sushi
watermelon oysters Rockefellers and
salami yeah this is tremendous this is
the beauty of a buffet he's getting it
yes you got the next headline take it
away all right next up the Daily Mail
reports the 2024 Fitness trend for men
is big butt
wow not only is it an aesthetic Trend
but men want larger and stronger glut
Maximus to help with their Sports
Performance so squat it up fellas now I
totally understand this because sometime
between like when I was 38 and 41 I lost
my butt Gio I can't see your butt so I
can't comment it on it unless you like
to stand up and take here you we really
go to R's yeah I got my wild in here
okay let's see
Ross
not Gio first of all those pants are
Loose as a Goose yeah not do any fa I
can't see th tokus and second of all I'm
sure you have a beautiful rumpus oh
thank you and should just feel nothing
but good about yourself good good Boomer
anything you want to share is there HR
around
anywhere my butt oh Drew all right
Drew
[Applause]
wow okay there you go
okay well I actually I'm not going to
show mine because no one's asking to see
it but I do have Ross wa wait no no hold
on when we were asked to come here they
said don't do your radio show whatever
you do we're doing our radio show are
exactly so let's have some fun Ross It's
Your Story well and speaking of hot
bodies it reminds me to give a little
shout out to our halftime performer
Usher who just showed off his skims
campaign oh yeah speaking of bodies yes
can and did you see hello hi
user yeah so um Boomer you're a premier
athlete is there can you show me how to
do a squat so I can look like Usher Ross
I'm a 62-year-old old athlete is what I
am but I guess I could do a squat yeah
show me how we're going to go like this
okay show us all come on J let's work on
your butt yeah let's work on come on are
you ready yes now I kind of shoulder
width apart okay not too wide Ross and
down up how's that Boomer I feel the
burn get your squats on and we'll be
right back with some more sneak peeks of
the best part of the Super Bowl
commercial spoiler alert I'm in one
whoa we'll be right
back w W
woo yeah